Y'a d'plus en plus de gens autour de moi qui.. Qui font l’acquisition d'un Mac
Mais pour eux c'est pas un simple ordinateur comme un pc..
Non non, pour eux Apple c'est une religion
Ils achètent leurs Macs, et direct ils font tous le même genre de remarques
Ah si tu veux Apple c'est avant tout un packaging, quand t'ouvres la boite c'est hyper épuré
C'est hyper bien pensé !
C'est hyper design
Moi par exemple mon MacBook euh, j'ai gardé la boîte  !
J'l'ai accrochée dans mon salon !
Cassiopée, il reste des Nespresso ?
Les mecs quand ils passent chez Apple,
Ils arrivent pas à se contenter d'un simple ordinateur
Tout d'un coup ils ont L'iMac.. Ils ont l'iPhone qui va avec..
Ils sont au courant de tous les produits Apple
Qui sont pas encore sortit mais qui sortiront dans 1 an
Ils respirent Apple
Ils mangent Apple
Ils font caca Apple
Think different. (Slogan d'Apple en anglais)
Et alors ils méprisent totalement tous les mecs qui utilisent pas des Macs
Par exemple pour eux un mec sur pc c'est ça :
Tu veux jouer à ...
à Call of dudy ? *n'arrive pas a prononcer le mot "duty"*
à Call of gucky
à Call of, quoi ?
Et alors les mecs qui utilisent...
Linux
C'est ça :
Allez
Viens avec nous
Rejoins-nous
Nous sommes déjà onze !
Allez viens
Viens !
On est bien !
Regarde tout ce qu'on peut faire !
Et c'est marrant parce-que comme les Macs ça coûte extrêmement cher
Les mecs qui en ont
Ils arrêtent pas de se justifier pour essayer de prouver qu'ils en ont vraiment besoin
Avoir un Mac c'est indispensable
Hein ?
Euh...
D'un point de vue professionnel j'vois pas comment j'pourrais faire autrement
Ah non c'est pas un achat par choix
C'est vraiment un besoin professionnel
FAUX !
En gros pour eux quand t'as un pc tu peux faire éventuellement du traitement de texte
Et des jeux aussi !
Comme... Comme Call of guly !
Et encore il faut que t'aies vraiment une machine de guerre
Peut-être que tu peux faire que du traitement de texte avec un pc
Mais au moins c'est accessible à tout le monde
Parce-que
J'sais pas si t'as vu combien ça coûte un Mac
Le moindre accessoire...
C'est un loyer !
Bonjour, j'aimerais vous acheter le clavier Apple, officiel, bluetooth, s'il vous plaît
Vendeur : C'est *** € monsieur
Non, non moi j'veux juste prendre le clavier
Vendeur : Ah non, je parle bien du clavier seul monsieur
Euh
bah je vais... J'vais prendre que la touche E alors
Ouais
*coin*
Non, et puis le p'tit truc qui m’énerve le plus chez les mecs qui utilisent les produits Apple
C'est que...
Quand ils s'en servent a coté de toi, ils te font une démo...
Euh, comme si c’était une pub !
T’appelles qui ?
J’appelle ma messagerie
Ah t’appelles ta messagerie ?
Ouais
Non, parce-que avec le iPhone, tu reçois directement tes messages vocaux sur ton téléphone
C'est vraiment pratique
Tu galères ?
Un peu, ouais
Moi, mon MacBook Air, il fait quasiment l’épaisseur d'une feuille de papier
Il rentre parfaitement dans mon sac
Et me suit partout ou j'vais
Ah t'écris sur un carnet ?
Ouais
Parce-que moi avec mon iPhone
*Sonnerie de iPhone*
Allô ?
*Rire*
J'ai plus de batterie
Même que à la fin de leurs mails, c'est écris : "envoyé depuis mon iPhone"
Non mais c'est juste pour s'la péter cette phrase, on est d'accord ?
Non parce-que quand t’écris un mail depuis un pc tout nul, dans une salle de réseau pourrie
Tu le précise pas en général
À bientôt
J'espère qu'on va pouvoir coucher ensemble
Putain !
Ah ouais, au fait
Siri
C'est quoi ce délire ?
Tu parles à ton téléphone devant tout le monde
Et tout le monde connaît ta vie privée parce-que tu doit parler à voix haute !
Envoie un message à ma femme, et dis-lui que j'ai hâte de rentrer ce soir pour lui lécher les seins
Bonsoir...
Bonsoir !
Ça a aucun sens, depuis quand tu dévoile ton intimité à tout le monde ?
Big tits, YouPorn
Tu dis quoi Norman ?
Ah non !
Euh, rien la... j'révisais mes cours !
Eh t'es plus étudiant depuis au moins 4 ans !
Ouais
Ouais mais c'est des vieux cours que j'ai envie de réviser pour le plaisir
C'est la culture !
Quand Steve Jobs, le pdg de Apple, y'a quelques mois de ça, est mort
Y'a des millions de personnes qui ont lu la biographie du mec !
J'veux bien qu'on lise la biographie d'un grand écrivain, d'un homme politique ou un truc comme ça mais...
Depuis quand on lit la bio, d'un pdg d’entreprise ?
Qu'est-ce que tu lis ?
Euh j'suis en train de lire la biographie du pdg de Carrefour
Non parce-que je faisais toujours mes courses là-bas donc...
J'me sens un peu concerné si tu veux
Puis faut pas oublier que c'est un mec qui a inventé le rayon fromage self service hein ?
Tous les gens qui ont fait leurs courses, ne serait-ce qu'une fois, à Carrefour...
Se doivent de le lire
C'est un régal !
Si toi aussi ça te soûle, tu peux partager cette vidéo sur ton mur Facebook
Si vous voulez vous pouvez aussi rejoindre ma page Facebook Norman fait des vidéos, y'en a qu'une seule
À bientôt !
Ah merde !
Ah c'est bon j'ai un autre clavier